hey dr. Burke here in this video we're
going to talk about the adrenal fatigue
formula this is probably my most popular
product and it's used as a recovery
nutrient for the adrenal it does not
contain any hormones it contains
nutrients to support the gland so it
supports a healthy adrenal gland one of
the products in here is called he Shu
woo and the reason why I use that herb
it's a Chinese herb because it's been
around a very long time and it's been
known as a great tonic for the adrenal I
recommend taking one before bed and then
if you wake up in milind I take another
one
some people might need two before bed I
personally take one before bed it
increases the quality of sleep now the
way people get energy is through the
deep sleep and also all the fat burning
occurs when you're sleeping so enhancing
the sleep is very very important to help
recover your adrenals and so this is
probably one of the best things I have
for stress and people that are stressed
out and for the adrenal body type so the
adrenal fatigue formula is a great
nutrient to support a healthy adrenal
gland